so a couple of weeks ago a trailer came
out for a rollercoaster tycoon world and
people asked me to do a rent on it like
I did for a rollercoaster Kooten for
mobile I have no clue why but I felt
like that wasn't enough to judge on
yachts like that was only just that well
revealed trailer video and if I didn't
have any information on it I would not
make a video on it let's let alone rant
about it but from the 29th till the 31st
of August at PAX Prime in Seattle Atari
gave away demonstrations of games by
requests and one of these games was
actually roller coaster tycoon world and
since some articles have popped up
including pictures and I looked at them
and I must say they are very promising
actually now actually I just want to
break these down and explain why to me
these are some very good developments
first of all the graphics look great
though that terrible cartoony feel
remains and it's probably here to cater
towards the more mainstream public there
is realistic lighting and the shadows
look very detailed and dynamic and if
you ask me the textures are pretty good
as well though they're still cartoony
they're very detailed and we've even got
realistic clouds I mean they're better
than the simple clouds that we had in
ICT 3 also the guests look more
realistic and less cartoony andronica
second three actually and the way they
interact with the stalls and even enter
buildings like that looks great and one
more thing to note is this building over
here this seems to be the exact same
building that was also shown in the
reveal trailer but now the textures and
lighting look a lot better and this
could actually show that they're still
improving the general look of things and
that the actual game once released may
very well look better than the things
we've seen so far secondly judging by
the square paths and the position of
rides and stalls in the pictures there
is most likely going to be a grid system
like Oct 1 & Oct 2 and Oct 3 of course
and it will mean that the game won't be
as flexible when it comes to scenery and
layout things but it will keep some of
the key features of the RCT series until
now it's good to note at this point that
this either busts the reveal trailer as
an animation
not actual gameplay since the reveal
trailer doesn't follow any grid at all
but I can't rule out the possibility
that curved paths will actually be a
thing but then again of course the
reveal trailer might be an animation but
the building that was shown in the
reveal trailer appears in the pictures
as well so it's definitely got something
from the game in it now third of all and
this is something that made me fangasm
as the writer of these of this article
explains there is a spline system and
this means that we will no longer have
to use the unsmooth limited one piece at
a time menu coaster builder and will
most likely have a coaster builder
similar to those of TPS and No Limits to
therefore even though there is probably
still a grid system coaster building may
very well be more flexible as rct3
creators of these days have plenty of CS
and CTS to choose the limitations of
in-game track have been one of the
biggest obstacles in the game and ICT
Ward may just have already found the
solution to that problem and don't worry
there will actually be a camera position
for the unright as well so that's also
cool as for the multiplayer parts and
something that many people were worried
about they most likely won't make the
mistake ea mate with SimCity now given
that
Atari has been a money horn lately but
it's probably not as bad as yay there
are four plots of land for a park and
each player can have their own plots to
build on in your Park and vice versa and
are allowed to only build on their own
plot this means you won't have your
friends possibly destroying all of your
coasters and torturing your peeps also
if you want you can play offline and
just claim the plots for yourself now
judging by this even though I have not
seen much of the game yet I am already
looking forward to the release there is
not much to judge yet but what I've seen
so far looks great and the screenshots
look very promising so this game
definitely is heading into the right
direction I've checked around the
community and have seen mixed reactions
some people greatly dislike this so far
and think it's [ __ ] but expecting
something like theme parks to do or a
mix of rct3 and TPS is something that
probably won't happen the RCT three mana
community is just too small
our city wall probably won't be perfect
for realistic theme parks in
architecture but I'm still willing to
give it a shot and also for all of you
who are wondering yes I am planning on
getting this game right away if I can
make videos of it too because so far I
really like the look of this and I'm
really looking forward to how this game
develops peace out